So today we're gonna talk about majority
rule and democratic competition.
Whenever we think about democracy,
there is this automatic,
almost reflexive impulse to associate
democracy with majority rule.
We saw last time that was one of the
things that frighten Madison and his
contemporaries that they wanted to limit
the power of majority factions as he
called them, limit the power of
majority rule. But we think, um,
today reflexively that majority rule
confers legitimacy of some sort on
collective decisions.
And what our agenda today is to,
to dig into why,
why it is that anybody might think
majority rule has some important normative
property.
Any,
anyone have any suggestion
as to why it might,
why might majority, why
should we care? You know, the,
the endless recounts in Florida in
2002 who really had the majority,
what's a big deal about majority rule?
Why should we care?
Any,
any takers?
Yeah,
I guess it was like a somewhat
utilitarian flavor to that.
Oh, somewhat. What utilitarian
flavor. Tell a Tarion flavor.
So That's interesting.
There might be a utilitarian
justification for majority rule.
Um, just say a little more
about what you have in mind.
Um,
because like if the majority of the
societies consents to a certain policy or
approves of a certain person,
it's kind of like they're making the
judgment that having this person having
this policy would increase their happiness
or their satisfaction with society
the most.
So maximizing governant by majority rule
might in some sense maximize you tell
it in the society.
That's a,
that's a certainly an interesting iPod
stasis and I'll revisit it in this
lecture.
Any other suggestions about majority rule?
No.
Okay.
Going once. Twice. Okay. Gone. All right.
We will, we'll revisit. Um,
we'll revisit this utilitarian
thinking because the, it's,
I think it's a very good observation to
make because although it's not explicit
in much of the discussion of majority
rule, I think it is implicit and we'll,
we'll come back to that.
The traditional justification for majority
rule was that it somehow identified
the well of the people
that democracy reflects,
embodies and it expresses
the will of the people.
But of course, you know, that just
puts it one step further back.
What is the well of the people?
How do you know the will of the
people when you trip over it?
One of the canonical formulations of
this idea is in John Jack Russo's social
contract where he says there's a great
deal of difference between the wheel of
all what all individuals
want and the general will,
the general well studies only the common
interest while the will of all studies
private interest and is indeed no more
than the sum of individual desires.
But if we take away from these same wells,
the pluses and minuses
which cancel each other out,
the balance,
which remains is the general will.
If we take away from the individual wells,
the pluses and minuses
which cancel each other out,
the bear balance,
which remains is the general well.
So people have spent hundreds of years
trying to figure out whether that makes
any sense,
whether this notion that
you find in Rousseau of
pluses and minuses canceling
one another out makes any sense.
And what sense could it make?
How would we know? As I said,
how would we know the general
will if we fell over it? And,
um,
it's often been the case that people
have tended to associate the general will
with the idea of the,
the will of the majority.
But going all the way
back to the 18th century,
there has been the contrarion mpulse
first noticed by a philosopher called
condor say at the end of the 18th century.
But that has since preoccupied
many theorists of democracy.
And that is that,
well actually majority rule doesn't
even necessarily reflect the will of the
majority.
What condos saying noticed was,
was a very simple fact,
which is suppose you have a society where
there are three voters and each voter
has a preference over, uh,
three different yeah, policies.
So in this example,
voted number one prefers a to B and B
to c voted number c preferred number two
proposed a c to a and a to B.
And number three prefers
B to c and c to add,
well,
you,
what Condo say noticed was you get a
paradoxical result because you have a
majority for a over B,
you have a majority for B of a c,
but then you have a majority for c over.
Hey,
and that seems like a
contradiction because if you,
if you dial back through your notes too,
when we were discussing,
um,
basic properties of rationality,
when remember when we were talking about
indifference curves and all of that,
this seems to violate the principle
of trans activity because you have a
majority for a over B.
You have a majority firm for B oversee,
and then you have a majority
of seat for c over a.
So it seems like what our individual
preferences can be rational.
Our collective pressure references might
be irrational in the sense that they
contradict themselves.
And so several things follow from this or,
um,
or thought to follow from this,
at least one is that this condo
say noticed in the 18th century,
but a famous indeed Nobel prize in any
economist called Kenneth Arrow proved the
theorem in 1951 in a little book called
social choice and individual values that
this is a perfectly general result.
And so if you have modest
pluralism of preferences, which we,
we were assuming,
remember when we talked about
cross cutting cleavages um,
on Monday we were assuming
it's important for democracy,
diversity of tastes and preferences,
then you can always get this
result with majority rule.
So that's,
so that has a number of
unsettling implications
because it suggests there's no
general will identified by the majority.
On the contrary,
if,
if things are put in one order,
you'll get one result.
But if things are put in a different
order, you'll get a different result. So,
you know, the white parliamentary
committees often work, um,
you have emotion and then you
have amendments to the emotion.
You always vote on the amendments first.
And then the final motion last,
so that another important Theorem,
uh,
approved by somebody called Gerald Kramer.
Um,
about 20 years after
arrows basically says,
if you let me determine the
order of voting, I, he, what?
Uh, what, what are the, the amendments
are and what order will end vote on them?
I can get any outcome.
All I have to do is know your preferences
and control the order of voting.
And I can get a majority to
appear to support any outcome.
So this is,
this is suggests set majority
rule can be manipulated.
Now you might say, well, and when,
when millions of people are voting,
yeah,
they, nobody's really controlling
the agenda and that specific a sense.
And nobody has all of that information
about everybody's preferences.
So people can't manipulate the outcome.
That might be true as well.
But it also suggests that there shouldn't
be much moral authority attaching to
the outcome if we know, yeah,
nobody manipulated that, that we,
that, that see wins. But if things
had been done in a different order,
B might have wine or a might
have one in this circumstance.
So why should we attach any particular
moral authority to the idea that c one,
we shouldn't,
it just an arbitrary resolved.
So footnote to this,
if one important takeaway from Arrow's
theorem is you should always be the last
person to interview for a job,
right?
Because if they're cyclical preferences
among the interview is over the
candidates,
you want the others to bump each other
off and then you come along at the end,
right? So don't say you didn't
learn anything useful today.
You certainly learned that they
call you for an interview. Say Well,
could I come in three weeks? Why don't
you interview around the candidates first?
So,
um,
majority rule if there is
such a thing as the general,
well majority rule doesn't
seem to identify it.
And the public choice literature that
came out of economics in the 1950s and
1960s basically converged
on that proposition it said
there is no such thing as
a social welfare function,
which is just a econ speak for saying
there is no such thing as a general.
Well or if there is a general well we
don't know what decision rule would
identify it and a huge amount of ink
has been spelled in trying to figure out
what
yeah,
what decision rule might identify
unambiguously something that we would feel
morally comfortable calling the general.
Well,
um,
and I don't think anybody has
succeeded definitively at that task
lock.
We always come back to lock in this course
lock has a somewhat different defense
of majority rule.
Now you might think that's weird because
most people think of Loc as somebody
who defended rights,
right?
We think of if you go and read about
the debates on the constitution,
the lock-ins versus the Republicans.
If those of you have
taken a history course,
the lock Ian's where the people who
if wanted to create the bill of rights
defend against the
majority, uh, and so on.
But in fact if you go and read lock,
what you find is that he's a
staunch defender of majority rule.
He says for when any number of men
have by the consent of every of every
individual made a community.
They have thereby made that community
one body with the power to act as one
body,
which is only by the will
and determination of the
majority doesn't say why for
that which act,
any con for that which acts any
community being only the consent of the
individuals of it and being necessary to
that which is one body to move one way.
It is necessary.
The body should move that way.
Whether the greater force carries it,
which is the consent of the
majority or else it is impossible,
it should act or confined or
continue one body, one community.
It is.
So he's saying that it's necessary.
The body should move that way
whether the greater force carries it,
which is the consent of the
majority or else it's impossible.
It should continue to act one body of
one community which the consent of every
individual that United intuit agreed that
it should and so everyone is bound by
that consent to be concluded by the
majority and therefore we see that in
assemblies empowered to act by positive
laws where no number is set by that
positive law,
which empowers them.
The act of the majority passes
for the act of the whole
and of course determines as having by the
law in nature of nature and reason the
power of the whole.
So that's locks,
defense of majority rule.
It's not that it identifies some general,
well, it's really an
argument about power, right?
He's basically saying,
look,
once you have a community,
somebody who's going to win,
it's a little bit like Nozick saying,
you know,
once you have those at
independents out there,
somebody's going to force them to join
just a real politic argument that the
power of the majority's going to
determine what the community does.
And indeed, if we delve more deeply
into other things that Locke says,
he basically says, look, if you
don't like what the government does,
you can oppose. But if nobody
agrees with you, you should,
as we discussed earlier in the course,
you should expect your
reward in the next slide.
If everybody agrees or if
a majority agrees with you,
then you can have 1688, right?
You can change the government.
So this seems to be an argument about
the legitimacy of the majority that is
very, uh, hard nosed,
realistic judgment about politics.
Not a moral claim that the majority has
any particular intrinsic property that
gives it the right to govern, right? It's
just saying, well, you know, there it is.
Um, the majority is going
to flex its muscles and if,
uh,
if it's not attended to it's going to win.
Okay.
No,
I think that we will see lock gets
actually a lot closer to the truth of the
desirability of th of majority rule then
Russo date or the people who are trying
to come up with a notion of the general
well or what modern economists would
call a social welfare function.
And the way you could
think about this argument,
particularly in light of the question,
the observation about the relationship
between majority rule and utilitarianism
is that I think, I think the best way
to think of what Locke is doing here,
it's a kind of negative utilitarianism,
uh,
or at least a cousin of
negative utilitarianism.
We generally think of negative
utilitarianism as the doctrine that um,
we should minimize pain as opposed
to positive utilitarianism,
which is maximize pleasure.
We didn't make that discussion,
that distinction when
we talked about Bentham,
but it's there in the contemporary
literature. So this is a cousin,
I think of negative libertarian
as a negative utilitarianism
in the sense that I
think that Locke thinks as of majority
rule and indeed of resistance to power as
a way of limiting the
possibility of domination,
limiting the possibility of domination,
and he's saying the majority can.
You can resist power if
power is dominating you,
but you're only going to win if you're
in the majority if you have the greater
force.
But why is majority rule the instrument
for limiting the possibility of
domination?
Why should we think of majority
rule as having that propensity?
Anyone got a suggestion?
Why should we think that majority rule
all things considered would limit the
possibility of domination?
Just a hard question. Yeah.
Well,
it seems to go back to the crosscutting
cleavages that we talked about the other
day, that if you're going
to be in the majority,
you don't know if you're going to
be in the minority and other things.
So you would eliminate the
domination that you put out.
You wouldn't want to be a dominant player
in presence for fear that there'd be
other domineering presence
is and other spheres.
I think that's exactly right. I think
you've hit the nail on the head. He said,
well it's related to the clause cross
cutting cleavages and one's not knowing
whether or not,
um,
the policies that get enacted are going
to be the policies that you want or
whether you're going to regard them as
being imposed on you and dominating you.
So the, the people, I'll come
back to your point in a minute,
but as, as background to an
industry show, I think why exactly.
Exactly why you're right.
And what turns on that you said,
think about another prize winning
economist who's theorized about politics.
This is a book published in 1962 by
the economist James Buchanan and the
political scientists,
Gordon Tulloch for which Buchanan and
got the Nobel prize in 1986 and Tulloch
was not happy. Um, and
that was the argument was,
well, we don't have any,
uh, a Nobel prize for,
for political science.
That's why they gave it to Buchanan.
Although you may know that
last year, um, in a slap,
in a slap at their own discipline.
In fact, for the first time,
the Nobel prize committee did give than
over our price to a political scientist,
to a woman by the name of Eleanor
Ostrum at the University of Indiana.
But that was then, and
this is now in 1996, uh,
Buchanan and got the recognition
and Telec was not happy. Uh,
and he as he widely let it be known.
So he has the intuition.
It's, it's, it's, it,
it is behind the veil of ignorance.
This book, interestingly,
longtime before roles wrote 1962 but
the basic ideas behind the veil of
ignorance,
what,
how would you think about the
decision rules that should govern you?
How can you reason about
that? And they said, wow,
okay.
What you have to think about
is two things. One is how,
how likely is it
that the society's going to do something
you don't like and what can you do
about,
okay.
And related to that,
you have to think how much do you care?
Because some import,
some decisions are much more
important to you than other decisions.
Why does it matter how much you care?
Because being involved in decision
making takes up time, effort,
energy that you could
spend doing other things.
So if it's some utterly trivial decision,
you're not going to want to
spend a lot of time on it.
But if it's a really important decision
then you'll be willing to spend time on
it in order to make sure your
rights are protected. Okay.
So they make a distinction between,
first of all what they
call external costs.
And the idea here is that
yeah,
as the number of people
in the society goes up,
the chances,
the chances that you're going to have
some decision imposed on you that you
don't like also goes up because there
are all kinds of decisions that people
could make. Right? On the other hand,
there are decision making cost too.
And as the number of people
and the society goes up,
the decision making costs increase as
well because they're more people to talk
to,
to negotiate with and so on.
And so what you have to
think about is the summer,
those two things, the, the,
the, how important is it to you?
Right?
Okay.
How important is it? Is it to you
to participate in decision making?
It's going to be how much do you,
how much do you care about the result
and how much time you're going to have to
spend on the result.
And what they said in a kind
of utilitarian calculus,
they said what you're going
to want to do is add a mop.
So you're going to want to minimize
the sum of the external costs and the
decision making costs, right?
You're going to want to minimize
that.
So when a decision is
completely unimportant to you,
yeah,
then you won't want to
spend a lot of time.
But when a decision is
really important to you,
you will be willing to spend time.
Okay?
And so then they said, well
sir, how should we think about
the organization of Society for
questions that people think are really
important?
We should have something like
unanimity role because after all,
unanimity rule is a veto of one.
Okay.
Right? Anybody, if you, if you have
unanimity rule, it's like the parade. Oh,
principal,
anybody can veto everybody's agreement
has to be gotten in the limiting case.
If you had absolute unanimity rule,
you can't do anything uh, without,
uh, that. Okay.
Whereas for less important decisions,
this point here where you minimize
when you're minimizing the sum of
external costs and decision making costs,
while there'll be something
less than unanimity role,
it might be a two thirds rule and even
less important things you might say,
majority rule and even less important
things than that. You might say, you know,
let the bureaucrats decide. It's
just not worth my time. Okay.
So Fort Buchanan and Telec,
there's no presumption that there's
any particular importance attaching to
majority rule.
On the contrary,
we should say for the
most important things,
we should start with unanimity
rule and then we can,
we can come down the ladder of
all we can think about, you know,
just steadily declining a super majorities
as things become less important to
us. And so the, the,
the argument was that for
constitutional questions,
it should be something very
close to unanimity rule.
And we should have entrenched was semi
and trenched clauses that are virtually
impossible to change.
And something that more so in whether
it's they're telling a story that more or
less reflects the structure of the
American constitution where amending the
Constitution does take,
um,
very hard to get super majorities,
but regular legislation takes a lot less.
And it's simply this calculation,
this self interested
calculation that I'm lead.
You too often,
uh,
often be willing to go with majority
rule and there's nothing more to be said
about it than that.
So now we come to your observation
and your observation is basically the
observation that you can,
and then Telecar wrong that Buchanan
and Telec are wrong because they confuse
unanimity is a state of affairs in the
world where we all agree about something
with unanimity as a decision
rule. And this, this,
your observation was
first made by Brian Berry,
who sadly died last year in a very good
book called political argument and was
developed by Douglas Ray who teaches
here in som into a important articles in
the American political science review.
And what Barry and ray pointed out was
exactly what this gentleman pointed out,
um,
a few minutes ago,
which is the hall Buchanan and
Salak story assumes we have,
we have an agreement at the baseline.
The hall Buchanan and talk story assumes
that everybody's happy with the initial
state of affairs. Uh,
and so then we say, well,
so we started that baseline and then we
say the things that are most important
to you from that baseline,
we will give what cried
unanimity rule and give you, uh,
every, everyone in the room,
essentially a veto. Right?
But then we'll work down from that.
But what ray and Barry said was,
wow,
okay,
what if we say that behind
this veil of ignorance,
we don't know whether we're going
to like the status quo or not.
Maybe we will,
maybe we won't.
But if you don't want to give any
special status to the status quo,
then you shouldn't buy us
decisions to the status quo.
Because maybe it'll turn out
that you don't want the status quo and
then you're stuck with something that's
impossible to change, right? And so, um,
what Barry and ray showed was,
well actually
if you assume behind a veil of ignorance
that your is likely to be against the
status quo as in favor of his status quo,
then you would choose majority
rule or something very close to it.
So I know if the number of
people in this society is even,
you would choose n over two plus
one or Nana and over two minus one.
If you are wanting to minimize the
probability that a decision's going to be
imposed upon you not knowing whether or
not it was the decision favored by the
status quo.
So there's a kind of veil of ignorance
logic in the Buchanan and in there,
ray and Barry critique a
big cannon and Tagalog,
which says that the presumption should
be in favor of majority rule or something
very close to it and less.
We want to buy us the whole
system toward the status quo. Uh,
and we don't actually have any
Altima at good reason for doing that.
It was even if somebody at
some constitutional convention
preferred to entrench
whatever it is,
the right to bear arms 200 years later,
we might not take the view
that we want to entrench that,
but now it becomes impossibly
hard to change. Okay.
So if if you say behind
the veil of ignorance,
we're going to be as likely
to oppose as to support.
There does seem to be a kind of negative
utilitarian logic which says if I want
to minimize the likelihood of having
decisions I'd are like imposed upon me.
I would prefer majority rule,
uh, to the garden alternatives.
Well,
that's all very well and I think that's
the barrier and ray argument is pretty
robust. It's certainly stood up for
what now close to half a century.
It's regarded as conventional
wisdom on this point.
I'm still in all,
it doesn't tell us a lot about
the dynamics of actual politics.
How does competitive democracy play out
in when we thinking about how actual
political systems,
actual democratic systems operate.
And you'll recall that
from Monday's lecture.
I said to you that Robert Dahl was the
most important democratic theorist of the
second half of the 20th century,
but I didn't talk about the first
half of the 20th century. And,
and I think the most important democratic
theorists of the first half of the
20th century who in many ways dall built
upon was actually an economist by the
name of Joseph Schumpeter.
Economist had a lot of influence in
democratic theory in the 20th century.
Schumpeter wrote a book called capitalism,
socialism and democracy,
which he published in 1942,
eight years before his death. And, um,
most of that book is actually
completely unremarkable.
Most of that book is a long and read
the tortured critique of Karl Marx.
But the,
the piece,
the piece of it we're focusing on are
those two little chapters called the
classical theory of democracy
and another theory of democracy.
And the,
I should say that those two little
chapters that may be the most influential,
uh, writings about democracy
in the real world, uh,
that have came out of the 20th century.
Now,
it should also be sad just as, as
a prefatory matter that the, the,
the title of the first chapter of those
two chapters is misleading because what
he calls the classical theory of democracy
is actually a neoclassical theory.
It is Russo's idea of the general will,
which we now know to be,
um, chimerical. Um, but you know,
from Monday's lecture that Russo's
idea of the general will was actually a
neoclassical adaptation because the
ancient Greek idea was ruling and being
ruled in turn, right? So that,
so showing paid his act critique of
what he calls the classical theory of
democracy,
we should remember is actually a
neoclassical 18th century idea.
But he starts from the
proposition that the,
the critique of the idea that general
will is valid. There's no such thing.
There is no social welfare function
as an economist would put it.
And he says he Shum pay.
This says,
let's think about democracy in
a fundamentally different way.
Let's define it as follows.
The democratic method is that
institutional arrangement for arriving at
political decisions in which individuals
acquire the power to decide by means of
a competitive struggle.
For the people's vote.
Okay.
And now he's going to develop this idea
in that second little chapter with an
analogy to the market.
He's going to think about
democracy as shopping.
Schumpeter says, look,
think about democracy.
Think about the the Po polity
as an analog of the economy.
What do we have in the economy
and what do we have in the policy?
Well,
one thing we have in the
economy is consumers,
right?
In the what are, what is the political
analog of consumers? Any guesses?
What's the political analog of consumers?
Voters. Voters. What?
Another thing we have in the economy
is firms. What's the political animal?
I got firms.
Anybody.
You have the mic guess various
candidates for positions. Yeah.
Parties.
Good enough.
Okay.
Firms make profits.
What is the political analog of profits?
Whoever wins the election hellos. Why
did they get, how did they get votes?
Exactly. So firms, one
profits, parties, one votes.
Then firms produce products. What?
What is produced in the polity?
Various party platforms.
Platforms. Yeah. And legislation.
And so when we think of the doctrine
of consumer sovereignty in economics,
what would the political analog of at bay
this one leap out at you?
But okay,
it's the idea of democratic
legitimacy is the equivalent.
When we say there's consumer
sovereignty and markets, there's demo,
there's democratic legitimacy in
the policy. And so we have this,
this basic parallel between the economic
system where firms are competing,
firms are competing for
profits, right? And they,
they engage in a competitive struggle
for the consumers dollar to paraphrase
Schumpeter,
right?
And parties are competing for votes
and they engage in a competitive and a
struggle for the people's vote.
And democracy is not about participation
or deliberation or all of the things
that people try to identify
with. It's essentially, as
I said, it's about shopping.
You shop for policies and
politicians and policies. Injustice,
same way as you shop for iPods and
Maseratis or whatever it is you buy.
Okay?
This is how we should
think about democracy.
Hugely influential,
right? Hugely influential.
And that what disciplines the elites,
what disciplines the elites is the,
that creates the democratic legitimacy.
Or maybe I should've put democratic
accountability there is the fact that the,
that the voter can kick the bums out,
right?
It's Gordon Brown's worrying about
this for the next few weeks, right?
The British voters, can
he have 'em out, right?
That is what disciplines
the political elites.
That is what prevents them ultimately
from exercising domination.
And so we think about,
okay,
we think about a competitive system driven
by politicians who are competing for
votes.
Turns out there's a big
tradition in American political
science of studying this.
That goes back to an a,
again,
another economist is kind of depressing
all these economists, but there it is, uh,
in 1929 who, who, uh,
hotelling who wrote a paper
trying to explain why is it,
why is it that if you,
if you look at a town,
any town you'll find target and
mmm,
you'll find a what,
what's another,
what you'll find a shores and stop and
shop right next to each other on main
street, uh, and downs,
develop this into a political
argument. He basically, he said,
imagine you've got,
um,
a continuum here from
left to right. So, uh,
that people with, with ideas, this
is ideology. People on the left,
I have people on the writer here,
well,
we should think the population's more
or less normally distributed, right?
So most people are in the middle and
some people are at the two extremes.
Well,
if you have two political parties,
okay,
where are they going to head for?
They're going ahead for the median voter
because that's where most of the votes
are, right? So
yeah,
you might have differences of
opinion within the parties.
I'll come back to that in a
minute. But basically, um, whoops,
why we
getting too far ahead of ourselves?
Yeah.
Parties are going to head for the median
voter because that's where the boats
are.
You know,
we said when they asked
to wherever it was,
why do you rob banks?
Because that's where the money is.
Politicians are going to go
for the median voter, right?
That's where the boats are. Now,
of course, they could be wrong.
They're going to guess.
So for example,
1964 Goldwater runs,
um,
running for president,
thinks that the median
voter is way over here,
but he's wrong. So he
loses then, you know,
1980 Ronald Reagan basically,
mmm.
Runs on exactly the same platform
that Goldwater had lost on in 1964 and
everybody says this crazy right wing,
not, it's going to be creamed. We,
we saw that in 1964 but either
because he knew something,
uh, or because he was lucky
or some combination. Uh,
it turned out that between 1964 and 1980,
the median voter had moved and Jimmy
Carter was wrong about where the median
voter was. Okay. So, um,
generally speaking,
other things equal,
the parties would converge to the median
voter or at least where they believe
the median voter is and the
people who get it right,
we'll win right now
that seems to have the implication
that particularly as polling gets better
and better so you don't make the kind
of mistakes the Democrats made in
1980 or the Republicans made in 1964,
the potluck parties are going to keep
offering exactly the same start offering
exactly the same policies. Right.
And indeed, if you look at the,
I didn't,
I don't know how much attention you
folks are paying to the British election,
but basically they're offering
the same policies. Um,
they're saying they're
both saying the other.
So going to lie to you about
what they're going to do,
but we're going to keep the national
health service, we're going to,
we're not going to cut this.
We're not going to cut that.
We're not going to do this to taxes
because they've done all the polling.
They know what the median voter once.
And so they basically
offering the same policy.
So I'll come back to what that
means for political competition,
uh, in a minute. Um, but
okay,
if that competing, if that basically
offering the same policies,
what are they competing over? What are
they putting in front of the electric?
If that basically both
doing the same thing.
They're going to compete over things
like, you know, character assassination.
They're going to say he's a vote.
He vote for me cause he's alive.
He says he won't cut the hell service
buddy. Well, the other one will say,
he says he won't raise taxes, but he will.
They said, well, he's this honorable,
he was involved in this,
that and the other scandal.
That's what they're going to do.
They couldn't compete over
personalities right now.
One way you could,
okay.
Imagine something that would change that
is if there were other variables that
kept these parties apart.
So for example,
we have primaries now in the u s and
of course the primary voters on the,
on the Democratic Party R.
Dot.
Over here probably normally distributed
and the primary voters in the Republican
Party are here.
If you have to win the primary first,
then you're going to get pulled down
here and the republic is going to have
pulled over there,
right?
And so what happens is if you have
some other force that pulls the parties
apart,
yeah,
then you might get competition
of a policy. Some people say, oh,
it's bad to have primaries
because if you have primaries,
um,
the activists get control of the parties
and the extremists in both party.
You know, the unions control what
the Democratic Party does. Uh,
and the far right controls what the
Republican Party does. It's true.
But the flip side of that is that when,
when the general election comes,
you actually have competition
of a policies because the
parties have been pulled
apart by the fact that they had
to win these primaries first.
Now there are other bad
sides of primaries, but,
but part of that point here is you need
to see that what it is that parties
compete over can change,
right?
So when we put in the general election,
the parties have been
pulled somewhat apart. Um,
so if, if you have something in
the structure of political parties,
it could be primaries,
it could be a strong, uh,
control of the party selection process
by the leadership or something like that.
Then you will get, um,
competition of a policy.
Now you could see some people would say
that's better because people get a clear
choice as opposed to just character
assassination and that sort of thing.
It's actually better for them to
compete over policies. Notice though,
if you do have strong parties that it
kept up ideologically apart and you have
competition of a policy,
you can get results.
Like in Britain,
British railways have been nationalized
and d nationalized three times in the
20th century, you know, because labor
comes in and nationalized as them.
And then the Tories come in
and d nationalized them. Um,
so you get policy alternation and that
could be good or bad. It's not bad.
It's a different thing to compete over.
So you can have competition
over personalities,
you can have competition over policies.
And of course you can have,
as we do in our system,
you can have competition of a pork
if you have a system in which,
um,
you have individual constituencies like
we do in the u s you have congressional
staff constituencies,
and then you have states,
each representative is really looking for,
not the national median voter, but the
median voter in their district. Right?
Or in this state, that's
who they're serving. Right.
And so there's a lot of literature
about whether it's better to have
proportional representation where you
have basically one national constituency
or whether you should have a system
in which politicians compete with one
another as to who's going to bring
more pork back to our district.
Okay.
So I mentioned these things only so that
you're aware that once we talk about,
uh, political competition,
we haven't settled, uh,
what it is that parties compete
over. Um, but champagne,
he did an address these because
shown pay to ultimately didn't,
he didn't care really whether they
were competing over personalities,
policies or pork.
The point was that they were competing
and they wanted to throw one another out.
This is the system to Harken
back to Monday's lecture.
This is a system in which ambition
really counteract ambition,
whereas separation of powers and all
that for the reasons doll gave doesn't
really work. There's no
mechanism, right? But this,
this creates a mechanism for
ambition to counteract ambition.
So Schumpeter and Darla,
much more sympathetic to the idea of
pluralism and crosscutting cleavages and a
competitive struggle with the people's
vote than they are to institutional
checks.
And balances to discipline elites.
Of course,
there are problems with Schumpeter.
I'll just mention them briefly because
we're running short of time and you can
pursue them, uh, in section, but one is
year and a half, two parties or
maybe three parties or for parties.
It's all it got polycystic
competition. It's not, um,
a very thorough going form of competition.
So that's one thing to think about.
Secondly,
um,
this whole thing doesn't address
the role of money in politics.
You will see this,
uh,
in sharp relief in the
state of Connecticut in the
next eight months were um,
the Republican,
what the likely Republican nominee
for Chris Dodd Senate seat has already
announced.
She's going to spend $50 million
of her own money on her campaign.
And so it Attorney General
Richard Blumenthal,
who's the likely Democrat has to
raise a lot of money. So it's,
it's not necessarily competitive
struggle for the people's vote,
but rather struggle for money.
And that has implications, uh,
which you should think about.
Notice third,
that this Shump Astarria and
story completely be values
participation after all
a buys into the Buchanan and [inaudible]
definition of the problem where we saw
participation was defined as a cost,
a cost of,
if you have to spend time
participating in politics,
it's time you could be spending driving
your Maserati and you'd rather be doing
that. That's the assumption, right?
How good an assumption is that maybe
participation is inherently valuable,
then you have to think about that.
Yeah.
And then finally, it really is a
minimal conception of democracy right
now. Some people have operationalized
shown, paid it to say,
and this is true in the,
in the comparative literature about,
about new democracies that we can't
call a system of democracy until the
government has twice lost an election
and given up power. Um, this is called,
she'll sometimes called the
[inaudible] two turnover test.
Famous Harvard political scientist Dude
recently died called Samuel Huntington,
came up with the two turnover test.
We can call something a democracy unless
it's been as turnover at least twice.
Uh, in one way. That's a stiff test.
Japan didn't meet it until very recently.
The U s didn't meet it until 1840
India didn't meet it until recently.
South Africa, which people crow about
as a new democracy has yet to me.
Did we don't know what would
happen if the ANC lost an election?
Would they give up hour?
Maybe, maybe not. Okay.
So in one respect, it's
a robust test, but,
but people criticize it as being minimal.
Say really this more
to democracy than that.
And we'll come back to that question next
week, but what I want you to take ways,
I think the enduring insight,
um,
of the Schumpeterian model
that really starts with locks.
Linking lock was very prescient.
He saw three centuries ahead,
linking of majority rule to this
idea of resisting domination,
that non domination,
this idea of resisting domination,
however you institutionalize it and
operationalize it and all of that.
That is the basic animating ideal of
democracy will pick up from there on
Monday.